alright everyone out it's a boy it's a
boy psycho psycho and this is my main
man d Trump right here now we're doing a
quest today that's pretty sure it's how
to get the companion Piper and it is
it's a story this century okay so I just
encountered her on entering diamond city
so that's like how it starts and
basically she was happening an argument
because she wrote like a an article that
was too real you know other she is chef
manner first letter under first um the
Mayor was like pissed off man but then
she said like you know come see me later
baby Piper glad you drop by yeah yeah
yeah oh look I'm just gonna say it
you're a vault dweller you might not be
wearing the blue jumpsuit but the
pip-boy and that fish out of water look
dead giveaways so here's the deal I want
an interview your life story in print oh
baby i like that nakon thought ahead of
came off I'll come with you watch your
back while you get used to the world
above ground Wow just basically offered
your whole entire life which is an
annuity oh that's pretty how would you
describe
we're Frau's a timely and I frozen I
didn't spend much time in the fall wait
he boxed you up in a fridge the whole
time are you saying you were alive for
the war yeah yes I'm over 200 years old
my god the man she's getting away she is
getting why hip shut it and yeah it
sucks you're all living in rusty shouts
killing each other smell okay that's
gonna be a fun one to float okay good
yeah big question why come the diamond
see you're looking for someone are you
who is it my son my son Sean was kidding
[ __ ] is like 200 years old Jesus [ __ ]
she is getting wet she might slip on her
own juices yes sure sounds like they
might be and people wonder why I can't
just look the other way for the last
part of our interview I'd like to do
something different I want you to make a
statement at the diamond city doing okay
threat of kidnapping is all but ignored
what would you say to someone out there
who's lost a loved one but might be too
scared or too numb to the world to look
for them um don't lose hope no matter
how much you want to give up don't wow
that you'll see pump is so good at
speeches you know the only thing with
the hat is you can't like see the
wonderful hair that's everything it's
gonna take some time to put this all
together but I think your story's gonna
be diamond city plenty to talk about
anyway I agreed to come with you right
watch your back just say the word when
you're ready thanks brah thanks brah
and that's it guys that's heavy bag oh
my god the quest is over has got a cycle
unless you shall go thank you